non
je viens pour demander des droits
bonjour à toutes et à tous à titre
liminaire je dois dire que je suis très
heureux et honoré de la confiance du
président de la république et du premier
ministre de nous confier cette belle
mission de porter la parole du
gouvernement est heureux d'être devant
vous aujourd'hui parce que je considère
que ce que ce qui se joue ici qui est
matérialisée par les échanges que nous
allons avoir dans cette salle est un
élément essentiel de la démocratie
les échanges avec les journalistes avec
la presse pour répondre aux questions
aux interrogations aux doutes parfois de
nos concitoyens est indispensable aux
liens que nous devons tisser retisser
dans un moment où une défiance de la
parole publique des institutions qui
vient de loin continue à exister donc
c'est un élément absolument essentiel et
j'aborde ces échanges de manière tout à
fait confiante je les aborde avec
humilité modestie je considère que je ne
suis pas là pour donner des leçons mais
pour répondre à des questions à vos
questions et je le ferai
le plus concrètement et le plus
clairement possible
je vais vous rendre compte des échanges
de ce conseil des ministres et puis
ensuite je répondrai à vos questions le
président de la république a d'abord
voulu rendre un hommage appuyé à edouard
philippe et à son gouvernement à
l'ensemble de l'équipe qui l'a
accompagné pendant trois ans avec une
tâche essentielle de bâtir les premiers
repères du projet de transformation et
d'émancipation porté par le président de
la république pendant la campagne
présidentielle pour commencer à mettre
en oeuvre les engagements
aujourd'hui ce que nous abordons c'est
un nouveau chemin tel qu'il a été
annoncé par le président de la
république et ce nouveau chemin
s'inscrit dans les objectifs que nous
avions fixés initialement pour
l'émancipation par le travail et par
l'éducation pour la souveraineté
nationale et européenne et pour
évidemment le projet écologique l'a
souligné que jean castex était un homme
de terrain de dialogue qu'il avait à la
fois l'expérience de hauts
fonctionnaires et de l'élu de terrain
etc avec son gouvernement qui a été
nommé nous allons amorcer un changement
de méthode profond c'est un gouvernement
de rassemblement
c'est un gouvernement dès 6 ans jour tel
que l'a indiqué le président de la
république puisqu'il reste un peu moins
de deux ans avant la fin de ce
quinquennat et que jusqu'au dernier jour
du premier au dernier jour nous serons
pleinement à notre tâche et nous
travaillerons d'arrache-pied avec
détermination avec conviction et avec
force c'est un gouvernement paritaire
organisée en pôles ministérielle autour
de grandes priorités
c'est un gouvernement de dépassement et
de combat le dépassement puisque ce
gouvernement est constitué d'hommes et
de femmes compétents pour agir au
service de la france et que tous les
parcours de vie sont représentées il ya
dans ce gouvernement
des élus locaux des élus nationaux des
grands serviteurs de la fonction
publique des femmes et des hommes
d'entreprise des professions libérales
c'est un gouvernement de combat puisque
il faut se battre pour l'emploi se
battre pour la reconstruction de notre
pays pour l'émancipation et que nous
aurons à mener ce combat face à une
crise sanitaire et une crise économique
historique et sans doute sans commune
mesure dans l'histoire c'est un
gouvernement qui sera élargie
prochainement avec l'entrée de
secrétaire d'état assure des missions
prioritaires
le président de la république a indiqué
que le nouveau chemin que nous abordons
s'articule autour de quatre grands axes
d'abord celui de la reconstruction de
notre pays
la reconstruction économique en nous
battant pour que les emplois tienne et
pour que notre pays tienne nous avons
évidemment commencé à le faire avec
l'ensemble des mesures d'urgence qui ont
été annoncés il viendra très vite le
temps de la relance la reconstruction
sociale avec les discussions qui sont en
cours autour du ségur
la santé qui vont s'achever dans les
prochains jours bientôt de la question
de la dépendance qui est absolument
essentiel c'est un projet social profond
et nous allons poursuivre et qui a
commencé notamment avec l'école ces
trois dernières années la reconstruction
environnementale avec un choix
d'investir sur des priorités des grandes
priorités et que les investissements que
nous aurons à faire poursuivre
systématiquement cet objectif de faire
progresser l'écologie dans notre pays et
de nous investir de manière durable pour
les français et pour pour le monde les
citoyens tirés au sort dans le cadre de
la convention citoyenne ont remis leurs
travaux et nous allons évidemment
avancer nous allons accélérer le cap
environnemental de notre pays ce qui
répond à une aspiration très forte de la
jeunesse notamment je ne peux m'empêcher
de le dire au regard de mes fonctions
précédentes mais plus globalement de
l'ensemble des français comme l'a
rappelé le président de la république
l'enjeu c'est de réconcilier l'ambition
planétaire que nous avons avec le sort
de chacune et chacun des français et
puis la reconstruction culturelle par
l'éducation par l'enseignement supérieur
par les institutions culturelles de
notre pays nos concitoyens le président
de la république l'a indiqué ont besoin
de ce génie français qui fait l'âme de
notre pays et de notre nation et puis
reconstruction territoriales il nous
faut travailler avec les territoires
inventé différenciée selon les
territoires
le dialogue peut être difficile mais il
doit en permanence se tenir et nous
permettre d'avancer
le deuxième axe de ce nouveau chemin
c'est le patriotisme républicain pas
république a parfois trop manqué à
manquer à ses propres promesses et donc
nous allons avancer avec des objectifs
clairs aller au bout de notre ambition
sur l'école qui a démarré je le disais
avec le dédoublement des classes porté
par jean michel bancaire il nous faut
poursuivre dans ce mouvement
c'est un défi historique pour notre
jeunesse qui a vécu un moment
extrêmement difficile avec le
confinement et sur laquelle nous devons
continuer à investir et des annonces
seront faites autour de ce sujet pour
l'avenir de notre jeunesse
le patriotisme républicain c'est aussi
la justice et la police des incitations
des institutions qui sont bousculés ils
font l'objet d' attaques d' attaques
politiques parfois pour les bousculer
nous faut il remettre au coeur de notre
ambition à travers une ambition tourner
autour de la sécurité de la justice du
quotidien concrètes pour les français
accessible et juste il nous faut
réinstaller ces piliers de la république
au coeur de la confiance avec les
français
et puis ce patriotisme républicain c'est
aussi l'égalité des chances qui est
immédiatement lié au précédent objectif
puisqu'il ne peut pas y avoir de
république et d' ordre républicain qui
se tiennent s'il n'y a pas cette
promesse d'égalité des chances et cette
promesse que les parcours de chacune et
chacun tienne au mérite au talent de
chacune et chacun et ne peuvent être
entravés quand la république a trahi
cette promesse
elle a perdu de sa crédibilité donc
c'est un engagement extrêmement forts de
notre parc de poursuivre dans cette voie
le troisième axe de ce nouveau chemin
c'est l'objectif d'apporter davantage de
liberté et d'associations plus large
qu'auparavant dans notre pays il faut
associer plus largement les élus
associés à plus largement les forces
vives de notre pays et au fond décliner
ce que le président de la république a
appelé 7e république contractuelle mieux
que nous l'avons fait avant associer
encore davantage avoir une politique
plus lisible pour l'ensemble des acteurs
des territoires de la république il faut
avancer également dans cet enjeu
d'associations et de république
contractuelle avec les forces vives de
la nation les forces économiques et
sociales les syndicats
et c'est évidemment ce que nous allons
poursuivre et puis le quatrième axe
c'est l'europe puisque nous ne
construirons pas notre indépendance sans
une politique européenne
plus forte qui soit il nous faut définir
notre culture et notre projet européen
dans un monde qui est profondément
bouleversé par les grandes puissances
mondiales et sur toutes les politiques
du gouvernement
l'europe doit être un relais pour nous
permettre d'aller plus loin plus vite et
plus fort vers cette indépendance nous
avons fort à faire nous avons beaucoup
cheminé
nous avons fait converger autour de
positions françaises beaucoup d'acteurs
européens beaucoup de partenaires
européens alors même que beaucoup estimé
qu'il était impossible d'arriver à ces
accords il nous faut évidemment
poursuivre pour que l'autonomie
européenne soit au coeur de ce nouveau
chemin vers lequel nous avançons
l'objectif de tout cela c'est de
continuer à tisser le fil de cette
promesse d'émancipation de donner une
plus grande indépendance à notre nation
pour elle et pour l'europe de redonner à
chacun la maîtrise de son destin
le premier ministre a ensuite rappelé la
méthode que nous allions employés pour
atteindre ce nouveau chemin sur la
nécessité d' efficacité d'association
avec les territoires sur l'enjeu
collectif que nous avions dans le
gouvernement à travailler ensemble à
savoir aussi dépassé les périmètres
ministériels pour avancer vers les
objectifs que nous avons en partage le
premier ministre nous réunira et réunira
l'ensemble du gouvernement en séminaire
gouvernemental samedi matin pour avancer
il prononcera sa déclaration de
politique générale la semaine prochaine
[Musique]
le garde des sceaux a ensuite présenté
le projet de loi organique relatif au
conseil économique social et
environnemental
c'est un conseil qui depuis sa création
n'a finalement jamais cessé d'évoluer la
dernière réforme date il y a dix ans ce
projet de loi et cette ambition elle
s'inscrit à la fois dans la suite
directe du grand débat national et des
annonces qui avaient été faites par le
président de la république pour
davantage associer les corps
intermédiaires les forces vives de la
nation et pour permettre aux citoyens de
participer à la décision publique il
permettra donc notamment de mieux
accueillir les pétitions de mieux
traiter les pétitions il permettra aussi
de
systématiser la pratique qui a été
engagée ces derniers mois avec la
convention citoyenne pour le climat et
de pouvoir la multiplier sur d'autres
sujets autant que de besoin voilà pour
les grands points qui ont été évoqués à
l'occasion à l'occasion de ce premier
conseil des ministres vous l'avez
compris un cap très fort solidement fixé
par le président de la république sur le
nouveau chemin que nous allons emprunter
les enjeux de méthode extrêmement fort
puisqu'il y aura le président l'a dit un
changement profond de méthode
et puis c'est dans ce sens que nous
avançons et je me tiens maintenant à
votre disposition pour répondre à vos
questions
bonjour anja nussbaum de bloomberg news
alors je vais commencer par deux
questions de mes confrères qui ne sont
pas présents physiquement aujourd'hui
questions du figaro
tout d'abord depuis le premier tour des
municipales gérald darmanin bénéficiait
d'une sorte de dérogation l'autorisent
ont accumulé exceptionnellement la
mairie de tourcoing et le ministère du
budget cette situation va-t-elle se
poursuivre à beauvau où le ministre de
l'intérieur va-t-il devoir renoncer à
son mandat local formidable parce que
vous me posez comme première question
une question à laquelle je n'ai pas la
réponse puisque le sujet n'a pas été
abordé ce matin et donc je m'engage à
revenir vers vous très prochainement
sous une forme ou sous une autre pour
vous apporter la réponse aux questions
de mes confrères de politico et de
france télévisions sur toujours monsieur
darmanin mais aussi monsieur dupont
moretti
que répondez-vous aux féministes qui
s'insurge contre les nominations des
ministres donc darmanin et dupond
moretti
darman en attendant toujours visé par
une plainte et dupond moretti ayant pris
position contre les mouvements mitu et
balances ton port alors moi vous savez
je
jusqu'à hier j'étais en charge de la vie
associative et je travaille énormément
avec des ong avec les lanceurs dalle est
d'alerter les associations donc trouve
absolument essentiel qu'on ait d'autres
hommes dans notre pays d organiser des
associations qui alerte sur des sujets
et qui fasse progresser des enjeux
notamment la question de l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes est rappelé que
c'est un objectif qui doit être
poursuivi collectivement est essentielle
et il faut le faire pour les questions
que vous abordez je ne crois pas que
l'on puisse considérer que ce
gouvernement porteraient moins haut que
le précédent la question de l'égalité
entre les femmes et un gouvernement est
plus que paritaire parce qu'il ya
davantage de femmes que d'hommes
un gouvernement on a vu des promotions
de nombreuses femmes secrétaires d'état
qui sont devenus ministres délégués à
cette occasion vous abordez de questions
extrêmement précise d'abord la question
de les investigations sur gérald
darmanin sur ce sujet moi ce que je veux
dire de manière très claire c'est que on
ne peut pas d'un côté sacraliser la
présomption d'innocence en toutes
circonstances et considérer que c'est un
socle essentiel de notre pays ce qui est
notre cas je crois je l'espère à tous et
considérer qu'il y aurait des personnes
qui par la fonction qu'elle occupe ne
pourraient pas bénéficier cette
présomption d'innocence il ya des
investigations
elles se tiennent et c'est normal on est
en état de droit mais mais mais on peut
pas aller plus loin que ça en
considérant finalement parce qu'il ya
des investigations il y aurait il y
aurait
l'impossibilité à exercer dans un
gouvernement pour le second point nous
avons dans ce gouvernement de très
fortes personnalités et des personnes
qui ont eu tout un parcours c'est
notamment le cas d'eric dupond-moretti
qui ont eu un parcours bien eu à prendre
des positions à travers ce parcours
quand elle exerçait des fonctions en
l'occurrence la fonction d'avocat
peut-être d'autres fonctions pour
d'autres membres du gouvernement
quand on rejoint le gouvernement devient
solidaire de l'action du gouvernement et
je peux vous assurer que l'ensemble du
gouvernement est solidaire de cette
action
pour le reste je crois que chacun à
l'occasion de ces crimes et de répondre
à vos questions à une question donc
cette fois ci pour bergues le l'ancien
gouvernement avait un secrétaire d'état
au numérique à ce qu'un nouveau
secrétaire d'état sera nommé pour
remplacer monsieur cédric haut il y aura
une nomination de plusieurs secrétaires
d'état très prochainement
évidemment c'est pas à moi d'annoncer
sur quelles fonctions et qui sera nommé
mais je vous rassure et le journaliste
de bloomberg sur le fait que le
numérique reste une très grande priorité
pour le gouvernement et que ça se
poursuivra notre question hier soir la
banque de france a dit que l'économie
rebondisse est plus vite que prévu je
sais pas si vous avez abordé ce sujet
pendant ce conseil mais est ce que vous
avez à ce que le gouvernement a la même
analyse et cela change-t-il les
prévisions économiques du gouvernement
alors on n'a pas eu de point sur les
prévisions économiques
ça arrive régulièrement au conseil des
ministres ce n'était pas le cas à ce
moment là en tout cas ce qui a été dit
c'est que la première ambition et je
voulais dit dans le compte rendu du
nouveau chemin qui a été abordé par le
président la république c'est la
reconstruction économique de notre pays
évidemment ça va se poursuivre
galibert terre je m'associe à un
confrère du parisien qui ne peut pas
être là pour vous poser cette question
au sein de votre propre majorité
certains s'inquiètent d'une coloration
un peu trop à droite de ce gouvernement
et du côté de jean luc mélenchon ont dit
carrément qu emmanuel macron est devenu
le chef de la droite qu'est ce que vous
répondez à ces inquiétudes et à ses
observations moi vous savez je me suis
engagé auprès d'emmanuel macro moment la
création d' en marche et je me suis
engagé auprès d'emmanuel macron parce
que je considère comme beaucoup que nos
moments historiques vivait notre pays à
l'époque et qu'il vit peut-être encore
plus aujourd'hui on a besoin de
permettre à des personnes issues
d'horizons différentes mais qui vont
toutes des talents qui ont tout envie de
participer à la reconstruction du pays
de travailler ensemble autour d'un socle
commun et vu un premier socle commun au
moment l'élection présidentielle avec
déjà un dépassement politiques et des
personnes issues d'horizons politiques
différents qui ont rejoint ce socle et
puis il ya un nouveau socle aujourd'hui
avec ce nouveau chemin qui fait suite à
la crise importante que vit notre pays
et donc il ya des personnalités
supplémentaires qui viennent rejoindre
le gouvernement autour de cet objectif
qui est partagé maintenant j'entends que
certains considèrent que un remaniement
c'est des croix et des colonnes on
regarde d'où vient chacun
moi je considère que il faut regarder
les gens pour ce qu'ils font et non pour
ce qu'ils sont ce qu'ils ont été en
l'occurrence on partage tous le même
objectif les mêmes grandes priorités et
je crois puisque j'ai lu certains
articles de vos confrères que ceux qui
avancent que ce gouvernement se serait
droitisée quand on nous fait les comptes
encore une fois c'est certain de vos
contraintes de vos confrères peuvent
être déçu sur ce point là puisqu'il me
semble que j'étais un article je me
souviens plus de quel journal a montré
qu' il y avait plus de personnes issues
de la gauche que de la droite dans ce
gouvernement mais encore une fois je ne
m'inscris pas du tout dans cet
argumentaire là puisque je considère que
c'est un non sens que de considérer que
c'est la clef de lecture d'un
remaniement certains d'eux
des membres de la majorité auraient
souhaité quelque chose de plus marquée
pour un virage social et écologique
les gens qui ont été nommés vont pouvoir
assumer ce cette orientation là
également
mais bien sûr pour moi ce qui
caractérise ce nouveau gouvernement
c'est les convictions et l'efficacité
regardez l'ensemble des membres du
gouvernement qui étaient d'un
gouvernement précédent et qui
poursuivent aujourd'hui ceux qui ont
rejoint le gouvernement qui n'en faisait
pas partie
conviction et efficacité pour moi ça
résume l'ensemble des ministres et des
membres du gouvernement ceux qui sont
entrés au gouvernement depuis très
longue date avaient fait preuve de
conviction extrêmement marqués et public
extrêmement fortes sur la question
environnementale barbara conflit est une
militante écologiste de toujours elle
est numéro deux du gouvernement
aujourd'hui sur la question de la
justice dupond moretti a fait part de
convictions extrêmement fortes
depuis toujours on peut avancer aussi
sur le social avec brigitte bourguignon
avec brigitte klinkert qui était
président de département immédiatement
engagées sur ces sujets là
j'observe aussi que dans ce nouveau ce
nouveau gouvernement un certain nombre
de ministères sont élargies à des
problématiques qui je le sais
d'expérience puisque je viens de la
gauche ont toujours été très fortement
portés par les personnes engagées à
gauche il ya aujourd'hui un ministère
chargé de l'égalité des chances
spécifiquement ça n'était pas le cas
auparavant
il ya aujourd'hui un ministère de la
citoyenneté pour travailler sur ces gens
lieu d'intégration auprès du ministre de
l'intérieur et donc pour moi ce
gouvernement incarne participe à
incarner ce nouveau chemin écologiques
sociales économiques qui est porté par
président de la république
centrait pour tf1 lci vous avez parlé de
ce gouvernement des 600 jours c'est la
manière dont le président qualifie
aujourd'hui ce nouveau gouvernement
castex 1 vous le confirmer cette fois le
président de la république nous a dit au
début de ce conseil en indiquant que les
restes peu moins de deux ans dans ce
quinquennat avec eux il va falloir
travailler du premier au dernier jour
d'arrache-pied pour arriver à nos
objectifs
il ya des nouveaux visages dans ce
gouvernement mais aussi beaucoup de
restants qui ont joué aux chaises
musicales pourvoi avoir tant on fait
bouger d'un mystère un autre temps de
ministre je disais à l'instant que
c'était un gouvernement
ça n'est pas quelque chose que je répète
du président de la république de
conviction et d'efficacité et quand on
parle d'efficacité il me semble normal
légitime que des personnes qui étaient
déjà au sein du gouvernement puissent
poursuivre leur mission soit aux postes
qu'ils occupaient soit sur un autre
poste mais parce qu'elle nous aussi
cette connaissance et qu'elle permette
d'être immédiatement opérationnels comme
les autres pour avancer
peut-être une toute dernière sur les
conclusions du ségur est-ce que vous
avez des informations à nous communiquer
sur caen ce qu'ont rendu ses conclusions
alors le premier ministre et le ministre
des solidarités de la santé ont indiqué
que l'objectif était de les conclure le
plus rapidement possible et il me semble
j'espère ne pas trop m'avancer que les
conclusions pourraient intervenir avant
la fin de la semaine
bonjour laurence ferrand pour france
inter j'aurais voulu que vous puissiez
explicite et un peu ce que vous
entendiez par patriotisme républicain
vous aviez aussi insisté sur le fait que
la police avait fait l'objet d'attaqués
qu'il fallait réinstallé ses piliers que
sont la police la justice et les colles
et ce qu'ils sont véritablement très
très fragilisés selon vous aujourd'hui
ce qu'a indiqué le président de la
république c'est que notre nation ne
peut tenir qu'à travers ses piliers que
sont la justice la police les services
publics qui sont bousculés par certains
qui à qui on porte un projet politique
de les bousculer que certains français
peuvent douter qu'il nous faut donc agir
en permanence pour faire en sorte que la
confiance soit présente
l'autorité ne peut fonctionner que quand
elle est perçu par comme juste par
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
et c'est vers ça que nous avançons ça va
donner lieu peut-être à des projets de
loi qui pourront sanctionner
éventuellement les appels à s'en prendre
aux forces de l'ordre
je vais pas aller beaucoup plus loin sur
le fond puisqu'il ya la déclaration de
politique générale du premier ministre
qui intervient prochainement le
président la république s'exprimera
aussi et donc sur le détail des mesures
qui vont être portées je vous renvoie
ses expressions qu'on plus importante
que la mienne désire tant qu il y aura
une expression sur l'ensemble du chemin
que je viens d'évoquer avec une
déclinaison sur l'ensemble de ses
priorités avec europe 1 le premier
ministre a dit ce week-end dans le
journal du dimanche qu'il souhaitait à
courte et en régler la question de la
réforme des retraites est ce que ce
sujet a d'ores et déjà été abordée
aujourd'hui dans la mesure vous n'avez
pas évoqué vous n'avez pas évoquée dans
les dents les piliers et si ce n'est pas
le cas qu'est ce que ça signifie à court
terme alors il n'a pas été évoqué
spécifiquement mais pour moi il
s'inscrit totalement dans le pin et de
reconstruction sociale de notre pays
puisque c'est un enjeu de justice
sociale que cette réforme qui a été
apportée pendant la campagne
présidentielle
président la république comme le premier
ministre ont indiqué qu'ils souhaitaient
avancer vite mais avancer avec cette
nouvelle méthode qui a été annoncée qui
a été réaffirmé ce matin devant les
membres du gouvernement c'est à dire
avec une association étroite des forces
vives de la nation des forces
économiques et sociales des syndicats et
du patronat
bonjour la mi-mars au delà fp vous avez
évoqué dans votre propos liminaires et
vous venez de le répéter que le
président avait demandé à appeler à un
changement radical profond de méthode
au delà des éléments de langage en quoi
ce changement profond de méthode est il
différent de celui qui devait impulser à
l'issue de l'acte ii du grand débat
qu'est ce qui va être différent
concrètement alors d'abord moi j'ai pas
le sentiment que ce soit des éléments de
langage et sentiment que c'est
extrêmement clair extrêmement concret et
je vais vous dire pourquoi je considère
que c'est concret parce que maintenant
on a entre dix maires un premier retour
d'expérience sur ce changement de
méthode à travers la convention
citoyenne pour le climat ça a été une
proposition qui a été formulée par le
président de la république à l'issue du
grand débat national que certains ont pu
dont certains ont pu douter
considérant que ce serait peut-être
gadget que ça fonctionnerait pas
peut-être qu'on n'arriverait pas à
mettre d'accord les citoyens très
différents qui viennent de territoire
totalement différent d'origine sociale
totalement différente et que ça ne
fonctionnerait pas est ce qu'on a vu
c'est que en se parlant en s'écoutant en
travaillant ensemble finalement 150
citoyens de se ré au sort extrêmement
différents arrivé à converger vers des
propositions communes et vers les
ambitions et c'est exactement ça
l'objectif c'est d'arriver à ce que
chacun puisse trouver sa place
participent et faire des propositions ce
soit les citoyens que ce soit les corps
intermédiaires les syndicats et c'est ça
qu'on va poursuivre et amplifier avec le
gouvernement de monsieur castex parce
que justement jean castex qui se
présente lui-même comme un homme de
dialogue de consensus
vous a parlé de cette méthode là est-ce
qu'il a présenté ce que lui voulait
faire et peut-être dans les mêmes termes
que ceux que vous venez d'en pluie oui
je les dis dans mon propos liminaire
jean castex et beaucoup revenu sur cette
question de la méthode il est
extrêmement attaché comme le président
de la république à ce qu'on associe
davantage ce qu'on associe les
territoires à ce qu'on aille vers
davantage l'innovation de
différenciation selon les territoires à
ce que les élus locaux puissent être
immédiatement et directement impliqués à
l'initiative
c'est aussi un enjeu d'efficacité quand
on dit qu'on poursuit cet objectif
d'efficacité souvent c'est en donnant
des libertés en donnant une capacité
d'initiative au terrain que vous arrivez
à avancer plus vite être plus efficace
et donc il a rappelé cet objectif s'ils
partagent évidemment
bonjour monsieur le ministre ma première
question 31 ministres est ce que c'est
ça une équipe resserrée
c'est une équipe resserrée puisque lé
resserrer autour notamment de grands
pools et de grands pôles qui portent des
priorités dans le cadre de la
reconstruction
quand on approche la question du
logement du ministère de l'environnement
parce qu'on a une ambition très forte
sur la rénovation thermique des
bâtiments
quand on rapproche le budget du
ministère de l'économie et des finances
parce qu'on considère que la
reconstruction économique et financière
de notre pays est un objectif
on resserre aussi l'action du
gouvernement pour la rendre plus
efficace en temps rapproche le sport du
ministère de l'éducation nationale
on va aussi plus loin on gagne en
efficacité sur sur nos objectifs et pour
avoir été auprès de jean-michel bancaire
il ya encore quelques jours c'est un
objectif très fort que de renforcer la
pratique sportive à l'école pour nos
jeunes pour les enfants à la suite de ce
que nous avons vécu dans cette crise et
avec le confinement donc oui comment
finalement il n'y a plus de ministre
15 alors j'ai pas fait les comptes
peut-être tout cas je considère que on a
une situation qui est inédite
une crise inédite qui a besoin d'être
efficace d'être déployé le plus possible
sur l'ensemble des problématiques qui
anime cette reconstruction est donc que
ces salons jeu aujourd'hui j'ai une
autre question est ce que vous savez si
edouard philippe a accepté la mission
que lui a proposé le chef de l'état
devrait à la reconstruction de la
majorité 2022 je n'ai pas d'information
sur ce sujet il ya deux arrivées qui ont
fait sensation c'est eric dupond moretti
et de roselyne bachelot
ce sont des personnalités assez
particulière et quel est votre grille de
lecture est ce que c'est une cresson
pourrait mener les manquements de
reconnecter avec un électorat populaire
d'avoir un gouvernement peut-être plus
ancré dans la réalité je dis tout à
l'heure c'est des personnalités
extrêmement engagés qui ont des
convictions très fortes qui les ont
exprimé de longue date d'une bachelot
c'est une très grande femme politique
c'est aussi une très grande mélomanes
quand on la connaît personnellement
féru de culture très engagé sur ces
questions politiques culturelles et eric
dupond-moretti j'ai eu l'occasion de
dire tout à leurs convictions et
l'ardeur qu'il défende est à des femmes
justice dans notre dans notre pays ces
valeurs qui porte très haut et donc oui
c'est un atout énorme pour le
gouvernement que les accueillir comme
d'accueillir les autres membres du
gouvernement qui nous qui nous rejoint
hier je pense à isabelle moreno a
d'autres qui vont venir nous rendre plus
efficace bonjour si nous le verrons de
france info vous avez vous parlé de
nouveaux chemins pendant la crise du coc
vide
emmanuel macron avait dit qu'il fallait
se réinventer lui le premier avait dit
le président de la république beaucoup
de français s'attendaient peut-être un
virage plus spectaculaires à travers ce
remaniement on voit que finalement les
équilibres politiques sont les mêmes que
lors du précédent gouvernement d'edouard
philippe est ce que cela veut dire que
les français ou une partie des français
ont mal compris les déclarations du
président de la république d'argentan
votre question mais je partage pas du
tout votre analyse parce que moi je
pense que les français s'ils attendent
un virage c'est pas un virage pour des
questions de personnes aidant un
remaniement je pense que c'est un virage
dans les actes et dans l'action qui va
être portée évidemment pour que ce
virage notamment sur l'environnement
élus pour cette accélération très forte
et lieu on a besoin de personnalités
extrêmement engagés pour le faire c'est
pour ça qu'un remaniement pour avoir ces
personnalités qui viennent avec leurs
convictions avec leur efficacité nous
permettre d'avancer mais à mon avis
c'est dans les déclarations qui vont
être faites parfois ministre par le
président de la république et surtout
dans les actes qui vont être portées
très vite et massivement dès cet été que
cette accélération sera perceptible pour
les français
les actes comptent les personnes qui les
portent aussi encore une fois les
équilibres politiques c'est ce que je
fais a commenté les personnalités qui
les portent aussi parce qu'on a besoin
de membres du gouvernement qui ont des
convictions et qui sont efficaces ils
sont capables d'avancer tout de suite
très vite parce que ya pas de temps pour
attendre et qu'il faut avancer au plus
vite possible
et le du char pour ses news donc le
premier ministre va faire son discours
de politique générale mais après
l'allocution du président de la
république
certaines voix dans l'opposition
regrette que l'assemblée repris ses
travaux normalement sans que le premier
ministre se présente officiellement
solennellement est ce que cette volonté
d' emmanuel macron donc de parler le 14
juillet ne va pas à l'encontre des
institutions du chemin classique qui est
suivi d'habitude moi je trouve assez
curieux parce que on entend parfois des
critiques considérant que le sens des
institutions c'est que le président de
la république fixe le cap et qu'ensuite
le premier ministre et le gouvernement
indique le chemin et la manière de
parvenir à cet objectif et à ce cap
hélas c'est précisément ce que va faire
le président de la république est ce que
fera ensuite le premier ministre avec le
gouvernement président de la république
qui sera un cadre un cap des objectifs
et a commencé à le faire je vous ai
rendu compte assez fidèlement de ce
qu'il a dit aujourd'hui et puis ensuite
le premier ministre définira les moyens
d'y parvenir et à ce moment-là parlera
devant la représentation nationale
merci beaucoup c'était une première pour
moi mais pour moi ça s'est bien passé en
tout cas enfin je crois et puis la
semaine prochaine je crois que c'est
comme ça qu'on qu'on dit merci